你要怎么度过你人生下半场的每一天，
你先想好这个问题，
其实孩子的世界里面，
他需要的不是一个左右亿摆的内心煎熬的天天不开心，
要装着开心的妈妈，
她需要的是一个真的幸福，
真的阳光，
真的热爱生活，
真的在奔自己的前程，
真的在好好爱自己的妈妈，
你才能给孩子做好这个榜样。
我在和我老公认识的时候，
本来不舍给我相亲，
给我姐相亲的，
然后让我前面就认识了，
当时我才22岁，
交往了没几个月我就怀孕了，
我当时现在又打算结婚了，
家里面想着也迷，
为了我的相体，
然后我们就结婚了，
他比我小两岁，
她就是属于特别不懂事的，
谈结婚也谈的不高兴，
反正就生活的不如意吧，
就和她父母的每一天都很不幸福啊，
娃出生了过后也是我的母亲帮我带，
但我一直住在娘家，
我就想到就是既然选择了已经有小孩了，
来了我就和她好好过日子。
当时结婚的时候，
他们家就说不买房时候我就说要买房，
因为我没不能没有住的地方，
我们在两个不同的城市，
但是我们相隔只有10多20km，
我在我们我父母这边上班，
她在他的父母那边，
他们家是做小生意的，
他一直没有固定的工作，
生了娃过后，
他也没有给我固定的钱吧，
他父母。
我每次答应给他钱，
然后会拖拖拖，
就我有点接受不了过这样子的生活，
一直都是这样，
小朋友大了肯定要一起生活，
我和他我就商量，
我说我们努力赚钱，
存钱买个房一起住，
因为我不想住他那边，
他也不想住我这边，
也到后面他父母每次都因为买房的事情争吵，
他父母也不愿意出钱，
也没有这个条件，
但是每个月能给一点小朋友的支持，
就给个一两千块钱，
这种我就专注于提升自己，
我就去考证，
然后我就特别特别努力，
特别特别努力的赚钱，
去年的时候我们就买了房，
大部分的钱都是我出的，
都是我这么多年还要花钱存的，
我在前段时间盯着他充手机的时候发现了，
因为我从来不看他手机，
他也一直以为我不会看手机的话，
他就没有刷过他的聊天记录，
当天晚上他喝了酒，
他在那里睡觉，
我一晚上就在看那个手机录视频，
然后把他所有的各种软件里面的我都去看了一遍，
这么多年其实我都一直在努力的为这个家，
而他却做了很多很出车了的视频，
不管身体还是经常这出车呢，
还是拼音呢，
就是具体是怎么回事呢，
都有他给我说的是是他在二三年的时候，
事业一直都有，
他应该是约没有，
他没花钱，
他就是那种很有嘴巴，
非常会骗女孩子。
的人，
遇到这样子的问题的时候，
我第一想的还是有小朋友和他生活是一直都是委屈着生活的，
我当时也不知道怎么办，
我也没给我父母说，
因为我的原生家庭是非常健康，
我想跟他离婚，
但是吧，
我有点忍受不了，
就是我的小孩儿是单亲家庭以后，
因为我为了我的女儿其实付出了挺多的，
又忍受不了他经常喝酒，
我给他说我给他半年的时间，
她这段时间她又喝酒，
晚上又很晚回家，
我问你一个问题啊，
当你发现他在外面干这些乱七八糟的事儿的时候，
他是什么反应呢？
他很冷静，
他第一的反应他说我肯定会和他离婚，
不是他有什么表现，
第一他冷静，
第二他也没有求你原谅，
第三他也没有任何表达，
说我要弥补自己的过错的这样一个诚意，
是这样不，
我就说让他马上给我买个车，
然后我再给他半年时间，
观察他做半年的变化，
那他给你买了吗？
买了买车花了多少钱呀，
按揭的能具体跟我说一下，
买车就是他付出了多少代价，
那他相当于没付代价，
因为这个车是按零首付的，
然后贷款在谁身上，
他身上，
他贷款那车登记在谁的名下，
他的名下，
那这叫给你买车吗？
对呀，
我当时就有点感觉，
我就不知道怎么办，
因为我也没给父母说，
谁也没说，
当时我就自己一个人的决定，
我现在就有点后悔那。
这车拿回来了吗？
拿回来了你开是不是？
嗯，
不是离婚了，
但是我的女儿担心我应该怎么做，
就这个问题我跟你这么讲吧，
就是你放眼望去啊，
我跟你讲去年的数据啊，
2024年咱们国家的结婚人数是610万对，
离婚人数是350万对，
那就意味着什么呢？
一半是吧？
那你看看人家这些离婚的里头，
难道孩子都是出问题了吗？
人家好多女孩子爸爸妈妈分开了之后，
人家不照样乐观开朗积极，
不照样挺好的吗？
我觉得这事儿你别把什么事儿推到孩子身上去，
你先想好你要怎么度过你这一生，
你要怎么度过你人生下半场的每一天，
你先想好这个问题，
其实孩子的世界里面，
他需要的不是一个左右亿摆的内心煎熬的天天不开心，
要装着开心的妈妈，
他需要的是一个真的幸福，
真的阳光，
真的热爱生活，
真的在奔自己的前程，
真的在好好爱自己的妈妈，
你才能给孩子做好这个榜样，
我真心的啊，
所有的离婚的姐妹们，
我真心的跟你们讲，
不管是儿子也好，
女儿也好，
她需要的不是一个忍辱负重的牺牲的，
装的很幸福的，
装的很和睦的妈妈，
她需要的就是一个就是他，
他自己过得非常幸福，
他自己知道自己想要什么，
她得到了自己想要的东西，
他自己很圆满内心。
自洽，
他内心很丰盈，
孩子们需要的是这样的妈妈，
所以你先别把什么事甩到孩子头上去，
你想要什么？
对，
还有一个问题，
他觉得他出了车，
他说还有我的原因，
就是因为我们分居，
经常没在一起，
他要我过去，
但是他妈又不能带着小孩儿，
其实我已经想好了，
做好了，
拖着难受一点，
就是我的女儿，
其他没什么，
其实我可以，
我是一个非常自立的人，
就是既然你不用依赖于他，
你完全经济独立，
你完全在这个社会上摸爬滚打，
你有自己的一席之地，
过得快乐，
有成就感，
有价值感，
先别管别人，
好的啊，
好，
就这样。
其实如果有一天让孩子或者说你让孩子感觉到你是为了孩子忍辱负重，
为了孩子那么痛苦，
为了孩子做那么多牺牲的话，
你以为孩子心里会感激你吗？
错，
这反而会成为孩子心目中的那种特别想逃离的那种情感道德的绑架。
真心的，
就当有一天，
你的妈妈总是在你面前去表达他为了没有跟你爸离婚，
为了你忍受你爸的出，
为了你，
他这些年忍辱负重，
这些年多么委屈，
请问你会心疼他吗？
不会，
你只会离得远远的，
你只会说，
我凭什么来承受你这些苦难？
记得点赞关注哦。